[Music]
Welsh Pub band The Declan swans used to
sing about the highs but mainly the lows
of being wrexham football fans
[Music]
the non-league club was heading for
relegation but two years ago came new
Hollywood owners a documentary and
crucially investment that's LED almost
fairy tale-like to a chance this
Saturday for a promotion back into
League football we've had the jackpot
with these owners it's just transformed
the whole town the community it's a
happy place to live everybody's talking
about football
um you know over the years when you've
seen youngsters with like Liverpool man
united Man City Chelsea tops all the
kids wear wrexham now yes uh yeah it's
great Brian Reynolds and Rob mcelhenney
the new owners of rexham AFC
welcome to wrexham followed actors Ryan
Reynolds and Rob mcaeny taking on
football and life in this small Welsh
City making stars of its locals like the
Declan swans well I can tell you it's
all here it's all real attracting new
fans from across the world had you even
heard of wrexham before not once never
never
what didn't even know how to spell it at
first Michael Starkey lives in South
Alabama and loved the film he's never
left the states but his first flight
ever will be here for Saturday's game
it's unbelievable
um I never would have thought even you
know three four five years ago that I
would be stubbing myself on an airplane
to go to the other side of the planet so
watch a fifth tier Welsh Football Club
uh but here we are and the day has
arrived and as we were still in the
company of wrexham royalty yeah
it's so awesome to meet you guys I love
y'all's music
but amidst the Hollywood hype is a
must-win game of football it's been 15
years of pain isn't it
in the the town and the club and the
club's had so many tough times and you
know we've had supporters who've
followed this club Home and Away through
all those tough periods and uh you know
it would be very special if we could
finish the job off for now the OWN box
and
and the guaranteed they'll be singing
Catherine oberton Sky News wrexham